in Star Trek it was known as a tricorder
as seen in this clip in the lab of
consumer physics they call it sigh oh
it's the first molecular scanner that
fits in the palm of your hand it
analyzes the underlying chemical
properties and materials using light
using the science of spectroscopy by
analyzing how light bounces off the
subject scio can identify cheese it
works on tomatoes it even works on pills
I gotta get to the blue one yeah I don't
think it's via grabber there's a blue
one scanning it illuminates the actual
pill understand it under nine chemical
properties to the cloud back and this is
advil PM by Pfizer scio doesn't yet work
on random objects such as my shopping
only on items already on its system this
is the exact reason we went for
kick-starting we wanted to create the
world's largest database of matter what
does that mean means that we need to
stand every little piece of material
that is out there bring it up to our
cloud so we can all of us together can
start understanding better the world
around us are we really going to say in
the future people walking around
supermarkets zapping their watermelon
zapping tomatoes to see if they're ripe
or sweet off that gone off I can truly
imagine people walking around the
supermarket taking zapping their produce
and knowing if that avocado that
watermelon the tomato is sweet or not
before they put it in the back the final
frontier for draws enterprise is to get
his mini spectrometer into every
internet-connected device it's certainly
the right size since this is it this is
the mini spectrometer una tries
photometers will go inside the scioto it
will ship by the end of this year if
only they could beam it to you it would
be there even faster and it got kin
Bloomberg somewhere over Israel